he was once feared and guarded as the
head of the country now Sudan's former
President Omar al-bashir is under a
different guard as he appears in court
to face several criminal charges which
include the illegal possession of
foreign currency and bribery
investigators say they found more than
one hundred and thirty million dollars
in his house days after the military
deposed him in April presenting the head
of a country to trial proves that there
is a rule of law in the country and that
no one is above the law this message is
not just for the ousted government but
to the incoming government the case will
resume next week we can't tell you what
the outcome will be but we can say that
we are assured that the case is going in
the favor of the defendant the court
heard that Bashir admitted to receiving
ninety million dollars from Saudi Arabia
he also admitted to receiving millions
more from the ruler of the United Arab
Emirates during his time as President
Bashir sent Sudanese soldiers to fight
alongside the Saudi UAE Coalition in
Yemen but investigators say the former
president said he doesn't know how the
money he received was spent nor did he
follow up on excuse he was also charged
in May for inciting to kill protesters
and demonstrations that started in
December over the rising cost of bread
which quickly turned into a nationwide
anti-government movement those charges
are yet to be heard in court charges not
addressed are charges that are brought
up against him by the International
Criminal Court which involved war crimes
crimes against humanity and genocide the
transition military council that al
stood him said that they will wait until
a transitional government is formed and
an independent and impartial judiciary
is set up and that body will be the one
to determine whether the former
president should be tried for these
crimes and if he is whether his guilty
or innocent more than 300,000 people
have been killed in the western region
of Darfur since 2003 and more than three
million displaced
international law experts say there are
many reasons as to why Bashir isn't
likely to be handed to the International
Criminal Court
recent research demonstrates that
warrants of arrest released by the
International Court do do not really
provide incentives for a peaceful
solution to the current transitional
government is composed also by many who
actively participated allegedly of
course in the massacres that plagued
Sudan since 2003 so we should start
asking the question on whether the
justice that we claim the ICC could
bring to Sudan would it be a facade of
justice but after 30 years in power with
immunity from any kind of prosecution
for people in Sudan the corruption
charges are a better start to justice
than none at all people Morgan aljazeera
14